It's time for the final ingredient, combustion.
Here, we're just looking at one-singled cell at a time. We're treating each cell on its own.
We're not looking at the neighbors unlike as we did with diffusion and with winds.
For this singled cell that we're currently looking at,
we have to take two different quantities into account.
The first is the temperature which we already know, it's measured in Kelvin.
The second is the amount of woods that can be burned.
Actually that should be something like a density of wood to be measured in kg/m².
As the combustion goes on in the cell, this density is reduced possibly to 0
and in addition we can use this density to model a variation in vegetation.
In a thick forest, the value of this density goes up and at a location
at which there's a clearing, the value of this density goes down.
Now, we have to distinguish between two different cases.
First, the temperature is below the ignition temperature
which is something between 500 and 600 K.
Second, the temperature is above the ignition temperature.
Let me put an equal sign in here to really cover all possible cases
even though in reality of this temperature, they'll never be exactly equal to that ignition temperature.
When we are below that point of ignition, the amount of wood does not change. It's not burning.
No heat is being produced because there is no combustion.
Later on of course, the temperature is going to change through diffusion, through wind,
and through heat loss but at the moment, I'm just looking at combustion.
In the second case, we do have combustion.
Wood is burning so the rate of change of wood with respect to time has to be negative.
That's called the burn rate and the simple model for the burn rate
would be to say that it's proportional to the current amount of wood.
The more wood we have, the more we burn and we introduce
a time constant for the burning that's called tB
The larger this time constant is, the smaller the burn rate is, the less we burn.
This time constant describes so to speak the time it takes to burn a specific amount of wood.
Now we have to think about temperature.
In the second case, wood is burning so the temperature should be increasing
and that should be proportional to that burn rate.
We need some proportionality constant in here versus something like the heating value
converting from an amount of wood to an increase in temperature.
This is our simple model of combustion.
Now let's add the effect of heat loss in all equations about the rate of change of the temperature.
We need to include heat loss which is + T amb-T/tHL for that heat loss
and the same when there's combustion going on plus Tamb-T/tHL